I found her abroad
where did you find it possible bro
[Laughter]
that's right okay so I'm trying I'm
petitioning Iran to get over here let me
let me let me ask you a question because
people always talk about the possible
Bros and people going abroad you know to
find a woman what she was she a younger
woman was she a child
because this is what people say they say
that you know people are going abroad to
find very younger women who are
impressionable
he's actually five years younger than me
I'm 43. oh okay well she's over eight
yeah she okay but she's you said you're
married she's not here yet
she's not here yet no oh okay
hang on whoa whoa whoa what happened so
you married over there
no I married online
well this just got interesting how the
hell do you marry online bro like what
the hell is that
so there is this uh gentleman that was
finally on YouTube he is actually
Filipino he married his wife as well
this was during the pandemic
so then this company from Utah
they do online marriages and they're
actually
um legitimate because the border the
What's called the um my bro my bro have
you seen this woman have you met her in
real life
yes I went over there for a month in
April okay so you met you met her for a
month and then you got married online
and how we got married before I met her
wow okay back back up so you you married
a woman before you met her
yeah before I met her physically yes
ow why
she could have been anybody I
think she could have been a catfish too
but then the thing is
um
I I went with that route because I
wanted to go sit with someone that was
within my religion
that was my problem before
all right which is fine you can have
your religion but I'm just talking about
like Common Sense type stuff like how
can you marry somebody that you've never
met
right you've never seen you've never
touched
and you're gonna you're gonna
wholeheartedly devote the rest of your
life to somebody like that
correct so
the way I see things is
not really like other people say like
hey this is the norm
um
it's definitely not the norm bro
it's definitely not the norm
you know what I mean and but if you
think about it what was the norm back in
the days you would go and you talked to
the
the Father the Father the father yeah
yeah correct but you but you but you but
you would have seen his daughter
but you yeah
come on brother okay so how how long
have you been married now
um it'll be our first uh our University
in uh January 18th okay and since you've
been married how many times you've seen
her
um just the whole month of April
so you've seen her the whole month of
April since you've been married and
since April and today and right now
we're in December
you haven't seen your woman since April
no but I I'm I'm playing with this whole
thing I'm gonna go back again probably
March
more than likely
are you said are you do you send her
money you send her money yes
my bro no no no no no but I what do you
mean by that though what was the
question the question
I I just I hope it works out I'm not
they're they're like I just I don't know
if it's wise to like be sending a girl
money that you've met once for a month
I'm married and married like someone
online that's not normal
like I I I don't know a single married
person that's done that you know but I
know I hear you I hope it works out for
you
um it seems like you're already too deep
in this really we're really
um into the church we're really into
worshiping we call each other we worship
you know
um
yeah that's very important to us
because
at the end of the day let's say
we get into an argument
well you have to have a standard
and you have to be able to look at
something to be able to mitigate that
argument so we just pray together what
do you I mean what do you argue about if
you see each other once a year
no no I mean
is it like you turned up late for the
for the zoom meeting or like is that
what you argue about like what the hell
no no like for example we had a little
argument and say that I I'm I'm trying
to do a bunch of things at the same time
I'm trying to like tend to my daughter
trying to go to school I have two jobs
and then I have my wife
so I'm trying to petition her
so she's asking hey can you
um
do this with with respect to the
petition I go I can do it yeah I can do
it just give me some time what do you
mean by petition what do you mean by
petition what do you mean petition means
uh you're getting her took over here to
the United States legally okay okay
so it's taken from April to December
she's still not over here
okay yes actually July is when I
petitioned her
no no children and never been married
Okay and like how and you just met her
through this organization or your church
so I I may go to the church
I I
hacks out for you I'm just saying
um
yeah like this is the thing it's like
you I think that men generally need to
be a little bit smarter with you know
when they talk about going to meet
people abroad or finding a woman from
abroad because if you've seen this woman
once in April and then you got married
to her and now you're trying to get her
overhead I'm not saying listen I'm not
trying to disrespect you
um
um it just seems like there hasn't been
enough time
that's been invested into this person on
a personal level for you to get married
to her and for you to you know I guess
trust her to be your wife she's in a
whole another country you're ever you're
in a whole nother country you're trying
to get her over here I understand that
you're trying to get her over here
um but
yeah it just kind of it just seems a
little bit
how much how much have you spent on her
like sent her money like you send the
money every month
so um she got a new apartment
I want to say
four months ago with with your money
no uh
so she was she's working as a registered
nurse at the Advent one of our uh the
religious um
the Adventist Medical Center are you
Seventh-day Adventist and so I'm
Seventh-day Adventist yeah I grew up
7-Day Adventists oh did you yeah I did
oh awesome so yeah so over there in
Adventist Medical Center Manila that's
where she works okay
uh as a single person you get to live at
the dorm for free at the hospital
she once they get married you have to go
uh abroad
so they have to pay for their own way
now okay and so what she was doing is uh
she was I think she said was she paid
like she wasn't for free I think she was
paying like 2 000 pesos
can I just get this in US Dollars just
like I'm sorry how much how much a month
for how long he was like 2 000 was like
a hundred bucks 100 bucks a month
yeah that's what she was paying okay so
that's how much you're sending her every
month
no no I'm sending her 140. okay
okay so the reason I'm saying 140
is because she found an apartment that I
was like
I think it was this is your wife does it
yeah
did the church get like a cut of
anything for setting you guys up
no no okay
okay the the church had no idea okay I
wasn't sure like the organization you
guys used or whatever it was no that was
just an online service that was a bunch
of denominations but I looked for us
when I was seven days as many of you
know I was just banned
band talk and to monetize on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible